finally this week the president made a
long overdue trip
President Obama focused on the struggles
of Native Americans today he made a
visit to the Standing Rock Sioux
Reservation with his visit today he
becomes only the fourth sitting
president ever to visit an Indian
Reservation that is pretty amazing only
the fourth sitting president to visit
ever I mean technically if you count
naan sitting presidents then Andrew
Jackson did visit a lot but you really
shouldn't count that but he did he did
visit but you should encounter during
the visit the US Department of Housing
and Urban Development announced they'd
be making 70 million dollars available
to improve tribal housing conditions
including money for mold removal to
which the Native Americans presumably
said Oh finally okay we are officially
square it was touch-and-go for a few
centuries there but at the end of the
day all we wanted was our mold removed
actually there is one other thing the
Native Americans wouldn't mind if we did
and it concerns the football team for
some reason not yet formerly known as
the Washington Redskins they still
haven't changed their name despite the
launch just this week of a new
emotionally powerful advertising
campaign Seminole Seneca
Mills
whoo Rogers to ronimal
unyielding strong indomitable
Native Americans call themselves many
things
the one thing they don't
Wow and for the average American that ad
should target 1/16 of your heartstrings
and make the rest feel extremely guilty
but the strongest possible push back you
can have after watching something
amazing like that is yeah but oh you're
right you're right we've got to change
the night you're right you're right
but one person remains unmoved and
unfortunately he is the only one that
matters Redskins owner Dan Snyder has
held firm under some protest that he
will not change the nickname of his team
Washington Redskins is more than a name
we have called our football team for
over eight decades it is a symbol of
everything we stand for strength courage
pride and respect oh that's fine then I
had no idea you had an ancient eighth
decade history at stake here you are
clearly a proud people who have suffered
greatly please accept my apologies Oh
chief runs without moral compass please
it's getting it's getting increasingly
hard to make a good argument for keeping
the Washington Redskins name if only
there was some emotionally affecting way
to convey that
there are many positions that can be
defended Steven Tyler still got it
cauliflowers the king of vegetables
camping is actually fun music you never
tire of mariachi weasels make the cutest
pets you should leave that 4th voicemail
every flight needs more Vegas if you
don't learn to play the recorder you're
Philadelphia is the cultural capital of
America if you want to get laid become a
magician Nancy Grace seems nice but the
one position that can't be defended is
this